ROB EASTAWAY: Can I show you
the symbol, first of all,
because that's kind of
at the center of it.
And I'm going to draw the quick
and dirty zequals, which
looks like this.
And it's a bit like an equals
sign, but it's zigzaggy.
And the reason for that is it's
sort of an approximation
symbol, but it's more
precise than that.
And the zigzagginess and the
zeds are supposed to make you
kind of think of zeroes
because this technique
involves lots of zeroes,
especially for big
calculations.
Really, what we're doing is
reducing every number to one
significant figure.
And let's start with a really
simple calculation, one of
your basic times tables
like 3 times 7.
Well, hopefully, everyone
knows that that's 21.
But actually, if we say what it
zequals, then we round it
to the nearest round number
with one digit
followed by a zero.
So 3 times 7 zequals 20.
OK, let's take another one.
So 5 times 8 equals--
bad example.
[LAUGHTER]
BRADY HARAN: Let's
do one below it.
ROB EASTAWAY: Let's
BRADY HARAN: Even I know
what that zequals.
ROB EASTAWAY: Yeah,
that's right.
Let's do 7 times 8, because no
one can ever remember that.
But I'll tell you
what it equals.
It equals 56, but it zequals
60 because you round it
ruthlessly to one significant
figure.
BRADY HARAN: It's almost more
work at the moment to do the
zequaling than the equaling.
ROB EASTAWAY: Yeah, I can see
why you'd think that, but if
we get onto a more complicated
calculation, I think you'll
begin to see why it's actually
quite handy to just simplify
everything at the first
opportunity.
Should we do a big one?
436 times 68.
Well, if we're zequaling this,
the first thing we do is
simplify these numbers.
So that zequals 400 times 70.
So we've simplified both those
to make this calculation,
because then it's just going to
be 4 times 7, and then add
on all the zeroes at the end.
So that equals--
well, seven 4 are 28, followed
by three zeroes,
so it equals 28,000.
But actually, we're being really
ruthless because we
just want a rough answer.
It zequals 30,000.
So 436 times 68 zequals
30,000.
And you know what?
That's pretty close to
the right answer.
Just check what the actual
answer is 29,648.
Now, in this case, that
is really close.
So zequals has been amazingly
accurate.
It's not always quite
as accurate as that.
But in fact, in most estimation
challenges, you're
really looking for something
that's an order of magnitude,
and zequals works in
most situations.
BRADY HARAN: Hi there,
everyone.
I'm going to interrupt my own
video at this point because I
can hear some of the
numberphiles screaming at the
screen, upset by this ruthless
rounding, this
dismissing of digits.
And I can kind of
understand that.
So I spoke to my graphing
expert, Dave Wiley, told him
about zequals, and he actually
put this together.
This is a graph showing where
zequals is at its strongest
and also where it's furthest
from the true answer.
I thought it might be worth
a look, and I've put more
details about it on my blog.
I'll talk about this more at
the end of this video, but
let's get back to hearing more
about what Rob has to say
about zequals.
ROB EASTAWAY: I think the most
valuable thing here is it's
giving you a feel for numbers.
Because there's a lot of
obsession these days with
people need to learn how to
do long multiplication.
Well, we all use a calculator
for anything difficult these
days, and we don't need, most of
us, most of the time, to do
a really accurate calculation.
A calculator can
do that for us.
But we do need to have
a feel for numbers.
And I suspect that many people
who use calculators have no
idea when the answer comes
out whether that number
is vaguely or not.
And the great power of zequals
is it just allows you to very
quickly work out roughly what
the answer is so you can say,
well, look, is the number I've
come up with, does it even
make sense?
Or have I typed something wrong
into this calculator or
into my laptop or whatever?
So what this is trying to
generate, more than anything
else, is a feel for numbers and
the power to be able to
say, you know what?
I don't know what exactly the
answer is, but I do know
roughly what the answer is.
BRADY HARAN: Is this something
people do intuitively anyway?
ROB EASTAWAY: I think they do.
I'm sure--
I have been estimating
for years.
And I think the difference here,
really, between this and
any old estimation is just how
ruthlessly you're simplifying
things to one significant
figure.
So when we did the tables, seven
8's are 56, seven 8's
zequals 60.
Most people don't think to make
the simplification at
that point.
So I'm just taking it one stage
further to become a bit
of a rounding extremist.
You could be even more extreme
than zequals, incidentally.
You could round 60, say,
we'll call it 100.
It's close enough.
I'm just a little bit short
of that extreme.
I would say I'm not a fifth
decimal place kind of person.
I really am a zequals-y
kind of person.
As a degree, I actually did
engineering, and there it's
all about having a
feel for numbers.
There's a joke about how you
can tell the difference
between an engineer and
a mathematician.
So you ask him what pi is.
And a mathematician will say,
it's 3.14 and it goes on
forever, a transcendental
number.
Whereas an engineer will say,
well, it's about three.
But let's call it 10 just
to be on the safe side.
BRADY HARAN: Is this the
thin end of a wedge?
I sometimes think that the
emergence of text messaging
and things like that has
really eroded people's
spelling ability.
Would the emergence of zequals
in a kind of lazy, rounded
estimation take away some of the
real skill and craft that
we want to engender in our
future mathematicians?
ROB EASTAWAY: I would say
completely the opposite.
If only your typical 14-year-old
frankly even could
just say off the top of their
head what seven 8's is, that
it's 56 in the first place,
let alone be able to then
round it to 60.
So I think this skill is missing
in so much of the
population.
Let's get them to this stage.
And actually, strangely enough,
I think the ability to
estimate, even though it's all
rough and ready, sometimes you
actually need a lot of math
understanding to be able to do
in the first place.
It probably has its most
common application in
financial stuff, working
something out.
You're in a shop.
You're working out a deal.
There's a question I've been
asking teenagers, quite
interesting to ask them.
You say, right, I've got 70
people, each want a Mars bar,
and let's say the Mars
bar costs 80p,
and there's 70 people.
So how much is that
going to cost?
How much are we going to
have to spend on that?
And they kind of know
it's seven 8's.
Maybe they know seven 8's 56.
But they'll probably say 5
pounds 60, because that sounds
like about what you'd
spend on Mars bars.
So being able to say,
well, hang on a sec.
70 times 80, it's like kind of
50 times 100, and what's that?
Oh, 5,000, oh, 50, OK.
So it's sort of, does this
answer make sense?
I can give you an example of
when zequals would perhaps not
be a good idea.
For example, if you're taking
your child's temperature and
you like to use old-fashioned
Fahrenheit for that and say,
well, it's 98.4.
Let's zequals that.
Let's call it 100.
Well, suddenly you're thinking,
well, maybe I should
take him to the doctor then.
Knowing when it's appropriate to
round numbers and when not
is kind of--
I've rather hidden that away in
all of the zequals stuff,
that that is a skill, a life
skill, an experience skill.
I hope they'll see the point.
I hope they'll see that I'm not
some ignorant person who's
imposing some impurity on this
great subject, but actually,
this is a handy tool.
I'm going to guess quite a few
of your viewers actually kind
of do this with variations
themselves.
So I'm just offering
one technique where
it's a shared language.
We all play the same game.
We round to one figure.
But I'm not saying
it's the best.
I'm just saying it's
one that's got a
name now and a symbol.
BRADY HARAN: Now, Rob's got a
book out called "More Maths
for Mums and Dads, The Teenage
Years," and it's in that book
he talks about zequals.
Zequals is just a very small
part of the book.
It's full of all sorts of cool
stuff, and I've put a link
under this video if you want
to check that out.
Also, that graph I talked about
that Dave put together
where we've had a look
at zequals, you can
find that on my blog.
Again, links underneath.
And if you want to see even more
from this video, where I
asked Rob even more questions,
stuff that I've left out of
this video for time reasons,
I've put some of those extra
questions and answers as an
unlisted Numberphile video,
and there will be links on the
screen and underneath as well.
So if you're really into this
and you want to hear Rob talk
about it more, because he's got
a lot to say about it, go
check that out.